if any of this is concerning to you this
was a guess i guess guys this was a
little bit of a concerning show today
this was a concerning show so we're
going to end you with hope because there
is a woman
by the name of kamala harris and she's
second in charge and she's good this is
a woman who knows her [ __ ] she's good
we've got video to prove it that we're
going to show you
in just a second this woman seriously
knows what she's doing and if anything
you know joe biden if one morning you
know fell down the stairs whatever it is
she'd be in charge and everything would
be okay you know i like to give you guys
hope and i think we do have hope
we have hope
in two words
kamala
harris
the governor and i and we were all
doing a tour of the library here and
talking about the significance of the
passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs and there is such
great significance to the passage of
time when we think about a day
in the life of our children
you